[Musique]
ici il faut retrouver il faut retrouver
le naturel dans une situation qui n'est
pas naturel donc ici il ya des choses
qu'il faut faire parce que si vous le
faites pas ça ne va pas marcher
dernier conseil du formateur avant
l'exercice pratique il s'agit
aujourd'hui pour ces jeunes de maîtriser
la prise de parole en public pendant
deux jours les membres du conseil
départemental des jeunes ont suivi un
séminaire d'intégration au centre
jacques tessier à la saline les bains
il s'agit d'un séminaire d'intégration
pour les 4e et des nouveaux troisième
donc ce séminaire va permettre aux
jeunes de pouvoir être en groupe en
convient et de découvrir un petit peu la
convivialité et surtout d'être suivi par
la femme formateur pour la prise de
parole en public
moi c'est important parce que là j'ai
rencontré beaucoup d'autres personnes
savaient encore fait je sors un peu de
ma bulle de confort j'ai rencontré des
gens de la possession j'ai rencontré des
gens aussi de saint denis
ça change beaucoup parce qu'on a tous
des histoires différentes en fait on a
tous devant la manière d'être arrivé et
m'a pas s'allonger s'est énormément de
liens de personnes que j'ai vraiment
très hâte de revoir donc le well
franchement il ya beaucoup beaucoup
liens qui se tissent tisser des liens
préparer les actions à venir
ces jeunes conseillers départementaux
auront mis à profit ces deux jours de
travail et comme de futurs orateurs ils
auront pu travailler leur prise de
parole et après surtout comment mieux
m'exprimer comment forcer ma voix c'est
à dire je suis quelqu'un qui ne parle
pas forcément fort et puis aussi
majestueuse jusqu'à qui ne bougeait pas
forcément les mains et maintenant j'ai
plus de gestuelle aussi le fait de
regarder des gens et de ne pas regarder
ailleurs ça me permet d'avoir plus de
sujets de d'éviter de bégayer quand je
parlais tout ce sont les futurs
politicienne de metz ce sont ces notre
jeunesse et j'attends beaucoup de moi
voilà c'est pour ça que je veux dire
c'est 30
en les écoutant à s'exprimer je crois
que il y en a beaucoup et on va les
retrouver
on va les retrouver sur les bancs de
l'hémicycle lutter contre l'isolément
des personnes âgées sensibiliser les
jeunes à la prévention routière et agir
contre les discriminations
ces grands chantiers montre bien
l'implication de ces jeunes à faire
bouger notre société
[Musique]